lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
tengamos un mejor entendimiento sobre la
estructura de la tierra y vamos a pensar
al respecto en dos formas diferentes
vamos a dibujar aquí la mitad de nuestra
tierra lo mejor que podamos
y como les dije vamos a ver esto en dos
formas en la parte izquierda vamos a ver
las capas que lo componen desde el punto
de vista químico entonces ponemos aquí
estructura o composición química y el
lado derecho vamos a ver las propiedades
mecánicas de estas capas
propiedades mecánicas y con esto me
refiero a que si esta capa es líquida o
es rígida o algo intermedio y vamos a
comenzar analizando el aspecto químico
de estas capas que conforman nuestro
planeta ya que este es desde cierto
punto un poco más sencillo la capa más
exterior se llama corteza y es en donde
nos encontramos nosotros en este momento
bueno asumiendo que ustedes se
encuentren en la superficie de la tierra
esto que estoy dibujado a verde es la
corteza es la capa más externa y la más
delgada también es sólida aunque eso lo
veremos en sus composiciones mecánicas
la corteza no es uniforme tenemos dos
tipos de cortezas la corteza oceánica
que es la que sostiene los líquidos el
mar la parte líquida de nuestro planeta
y la corteza continental que es donde se
encuentran obviamente los continentes y
aquí voy a dibujar también la corteza
oceánica que es esta parte
a la más delgada y ahora voy a dibujar
la parte continental o la corteza
continental que es más gruesa aquí en
amarillo la voy a poner acá
es más gruesa y menos densa que la
corteza oceánica así que esto es corteza
continental corteza continental y está
verde delgadita es la corteza oceánica
la corteza oceánica es bastante delgada
medirá unos tendrá unos 5 ó 10
kilómetros de grosor y como les comenté
esto se refiere a la parte de la corteza
en donde se encuentran los océanos si
ustedes fueron a un océano llegaron al
fondo del océano y a partir de ahí
excavaron hacia abajo tendrían que
excavar unos 5 o 10 kilómetros para
poder atravesar la corteza por otra
parte la corteza continental es más
gruesa bastante más gruesa tiene un
grosor de entre 10 a 70 kilómetros aquí
escribimos 10 a 70 kilómetros de grueso
y obviamente ambas cortezas son rígidas
abajo de esta capa si lo vemos desde el
punto de vista de composición química
esta siguiente capa es la capa más
gruesa
es el manto lo dibujamos aquí en rojo el
manto no sé por qué siempre se me
dificulta dibujar la parte derecha de
este diagrama aquí va de nuevo
y más o menos así
aquí está el manto y una vez que lo
hemos diferenciado de la corteza vemos
que está compuesto de diferentes tipos
de rocas y podemos ir aún más al fondo
el grueso del manto que comienza justo
por debajo de la corteza tanto de la
oceánica como de la continental tiene un
grosor de dos mil novecientos kilómetros
por lo que pueden ver que es mucho mucho
más gruesa que la corteza terrestre
recordamos que la corteza va de los 5 a
los 70 kilómetros y el manto es de 2.900
kilómetros de profundidad o de grueso de
todas maneras les comento que este
dibujo no está hecho de escala y si
fuéramos todavía más profundo que el
manto nos encontraríamos con la parte
más densa de la tierra que es el núcleo
una de las cosas que caracteriza estas
capas sobre todo desde el punto de vista
mecánico es que mientras más profundo se
llegue hacia ciento de la tierra
tendremos los elementos más densos hacia
el centro y también tendremos más calor
y más presión
así que tenemos los elementos más
pesados que son atraídos hacia el centro
y los menos densos van a quedar más
hacia la superficie y eso también se
aplica incluso con los gases que van a
formar burbujitas y van a salir hacia la
parte superior de nuestra atmósfera así
que en general las cosas más pesadas se
van a encontrar en el núcleo y las más
ligeras se van a encontrar en las partes
superiores por lo tanto la composición
del núcleo es fundamentalmente diferente
de la del manto y la corteza se piensa
que está compuesto fundamentalmente de
metales en particular de hierro y níquel
y ahora vamos a pensar en estas mismas
capas pero desde el punto de vista
mecánico que es líquido que es rígido y
sólido y que está intermedio así que la
capa rígida más externa está compuesta
por la corteza tanto continental como
oceánica
y la parte superior más fría del manto
así que permítanme dibujar esto aquí
esta capa de acá
lo que estoy dibujando aquí en rosa es
la parte más fría rígida y sólida del
manto esto de aquí es la parte del manto
que es roca sólida y fría aunque su
composición es diferente de la corteza
continental pero ambos son rígidos
si combinamos esta sección del manto con
la corteza entonces llamaremos a esto la
litosfera esta parte es la litosfera
y esto abarca bueno dependiendo en donde
se encuentren en la superficie de la
tierra esto tiene unos 200 kilómetros de
espesor de 10 a 200 km de espesor
aunque su mayor parte se encuentra más
cercano a este límite superior de los
200 km hay algunos lugares en donde el
manto ha disuelto un parte de la
litosfera pero le vemos más adelante de
esto justo cuando comenzamos a hablar
sobre las capas tectónicas y cuando
hablemos de ello veremos que la
litosfera se compone de capas y ésta a
su vez está sobre las capas más
inferiores del manto recordemos entonces
que la litosfera es rígida es sólida
y está compuesta de la corteza y la capa
superior del mando ahora si nos vamos un
poco más profundo la temperatura y la
presión van a aumentar y cuando la
temperatura se incrementa lo suficiente
tendremos la misma composición que las
capas superiores de el manto las rígidas
pero ahora éstas estarán no del todo
líquidas pues aún transmiten el tipo de
onda que los líquidos no pueden
transmitir tiene algunas propiedades de
los fluidos es decir puede fluir pero no
es un líquido o como tal es mucho más
viscoso de lo que asociamos normalmente
con los fluidos finalmente no es ni
rígido ni sólido pero sin embargo
tampoco es un líquido y esta parte se
llama hazte noosfera
es la parte del manto que es un poquito
más gelatinoso y es de esta forma porque
las temperaturas comienzan a ser tan
altas que las rocas comienzan a fundirse
así que aquí escribimos el nombre de
esta capa en magenta es hace no esfera
vaya nombre hasta el osf era y la aste
los fra comienza justo donde termina la
litosfera y esa parte gelatinosa en
donde se encuentran apoyadas las placas
tectónicas y es lo que permite que éstas
se muevan así que comienza justo donde
termina la biosfera y tiene una
profundidad
d
660 km aquí lo escribimos 660 kilómetros
de profundidad
y si nos vamos más profundo todavía que
esto veremos que tanto la presión como
la temperatura continúan aumentando y
son tan grandes que aunque la
temperatura es muy alta la presión es
tan grande que este material ya no puede
tener la propiedad de fluido ya no se
puede mover pueden imaginarse qué bueno
si tenemos aquí algunas moléculas estas
moléculas pueden deslizarse entre ellas
aunque fuera lentamente pero si
aumentamos la presión estas moléculas
van a estar mucho más juntas y ya no
obtendrán ese movimiento y es
esencialmente lo que está sucediendo en
estas capas inferiores del manto y esa
capa de intermedia se llama mesosfera
la mesosfera y aquí no se confundan con
esta capa de la tierra que se llama
mesosfera porque también nuestra
atmósfera tiene una parte que se le
llama mesosfera también pero son
diferentes
en esta parte la presión es tan grande
que el material de nuevo se ha vuelto
rígido en esta sección el material está
definitivamente sólido
y si ahora nos vamos todavía más
profundo pues que creen vamos a llegar
al núcleo al núcleo metálico de nuestro
planeta las temperaturas son tan altas
que aún bueno las presiones también son
grandes por el cambio de composición de
material aquí ya que aquí tenemos en su
mayor parte metales los metales a estas
temperaturas son fluidos son líquidos
así que tendremos que la parte externa
del núcleo es líquida
y todo el núcleo hasta donde sabemos
tiene la misma composición es solamente
la parte exterior del núcleo la que se
encuentra en forma líquida debido a la
temperatura ya la presión ya que la
temperatura es alta para mantener un
líquido pero la presión no es tan grande
como para evitar que esté en forma
líquida ahora si nos vamos todavía más
profundo que eso entonces si la presión
será tan grande que va a evitar que este
metal esté en forma líquida por lo que
el centro del núcleo será sólido la
parte más interna de la tierra va a
estar en forma sólida bueno de hecho se
me estaba olvidando a poner las
profundidades que tiene cada capa si el
manto termina en una profundidad de dos
mil novecientos kilómetros también la
mesosfera es en donde va a terminar en
los dos mil novecientos kilómetros
ya que es la parte inferior del manto
si nos vamos a darle más profundo
veremos que la parte líquida del núcleo
se extiende desde los 2 mil 900 km hasta
aproximadamente y de hecho creo que debo
dibujar la parte del núcleo líquido
mucho más grande porque llega hasta 5
mil 100 km de profundidad y obviamente
ya nos quedaría el centro del núcleo el
cual se encuentra pues en el centro de
la tierra y el radio de la tierra es de
6 mil 400 kilómetros espero que con esto
ustedes comprenden mejor cuando las
personas se refieren a la parte de la
litosfera o la mesosfera en fin todos
estos elementos que componen la tierra
desde el punto de vista mecánico núcleo
sólido núcleo líquido mesosfera esta
parte del manto que es medio gelatinosa
astin o esfera litosfera y corteza la
corteza es donde normalmente nos
encontramos todos nosotros en la
superficie de la tierra